[Music]
hey welcome back the GameSpot's
continuing coverage of Gamescom 2014 i'm
time go to our camera and robinson danny
we double teamed some [ __ ]
oh we sure did and I got to play the
shangri-la I say that really a
shangri-la section we're socially quite
interesting so what they're doing that
with this is throughout the world of far
cry 4 you'll find these paintings and
you can like move inside them and it
will trigger this new shangri-la mission
which is like set in our enclosed area
lots of space to explore and the color
palette is all red and you've got this
bow and you've got this Tiger who helps
you out but it's just it's quite a nice
it's like a side mission departure
departure things like the usual for
crafts or experience when you're like
wandering around doing you want it's
quite focused it's it seemed like it was
pretty like straight up linear where you
had one objective to do there was some
variation in the paths you could get to
that but not really that much and it was
basically focusing on this this yo and
the C emphasis was very much with
stealth so you're meant to like see the
guys that with the bow or with they're
gonna take their time use your tiger so
you could actually and the same way you
would tag people normally in Far Cry you
can say hey tiger get that give Tiger
eat that dude yeah and he can be
stealthy to return envisions parents so
apparently they're gonna have to do one
of these that they're optional but then
once you actually complete that first
one you can you know do them if you want
to and if you do then you get special
abilities so it's it's another one of
the many side quests you can do bark
right for I got to play something in the
in the mountains which was also kind of
localized
focused demo so obviously the world of
far cry 4 is quite big and but if you
want to get to the top of the peaks
said of you actually having to check the
whole way off they basically just made
these kind of instance levels so what I
played was a mission where I basically
had to knife kill one of the main bodies
antagonists like general Justin like a
captain of their the base yeah it's the
same ways you have the bases in Far Cry
3 this is like one that on the top of
like a Himalayan mountain but it's great
to see that was like you could take the
my stealthily you could use their guns
you also had bait a lot but favorite bad
meat bet you like released a bear then
through bait it was like you reminded me
of like that Lions things your house
life to where you're just throwing meat
at dudes and this bear just comes out of
nowhere in malls they had in Blood
Dragon as well didn't oh you had
actually I keep bringing the done badly
and didn't ever come at an hour yeah but
again it was like another sort of a
focus to have to do this kind of level
which I guess is something very easy to
show with the games convention because I
can say it's 15 minutes or so so it
seems fun it felt really like Far Cry 3
which it was no bad thing it looked good
I got to use a wingsuit which was
ridiculous and then when it when they
literally got to the end of the wingsuit
section you're flying down off the
mountains you hit a level complete
screen which I'm guessing then brings
you back to the game so we haven't seen
too much of the open-world our cry for
stuff if it's anything like what we've
seen from this it'll probably be similar
to Far Cry 3 these levels perform books
so they're showing us how their Guinness
supplement the main game in the world
with these like shangri-la bits of the
side we get more abilities and these
like special missions right up into
Pete's which I guess are about while
look here on top balloons projects do
you want to play Far Cry 4 after playing
up Julie absolutely and that's my
probably most high gave me this year
alright alright well from more coverage
of Far Cry 4 and games come in general
stay tuned into games [ __ ] off
[Music]